we're going to show you Palpatine
himself here is Klaus Schwab saying that
the world will no longer be run by the
USA instead he's got plans for the wef
and BlackRock okay
who will really commands for sinus
revolution of this technology like
artificial intelligence what's your
sense of who's best placed at this time
to lead the world into the fourth
Industrial Revolution because you pretty
much created this term we're seeing the
kind of technological strides that China
has made with Huawei with the 5G
technology do you believe that this
could potentially be China's time once
again we we should make here again a
let's say a differentiation on the one
hand we have uh State capitalism on the
other hand we have shareholder or
private capitalism so it's a clash
between two systems I I believe that
state capitalism in the short term it's
a short term provides certain advantages
because you can mobilize in a
concentrated way a lot of resources to
reach a specific objective but I believe
that the future is not State capitalism
or shareholder capitalism the future is
what I call
stakehold oil capitalism which is
combined with the social responsibility
the last line there is the really scary
part stakeholder capitalism is combined
with this social this idea of social
responsibility this is ESG we've done
several shows on this Glenn Beck wrote a
fantastic book on it I had Vivek
ramaswami on to talk about it this idea
that these companies and this is what
fascism is when governments work with
giant corporations to instill a
political belief on the people and
that's what they're doing so they get
these diversity Equity inclusion boards
at all of these big companies because
they're being socially responsible as
ESG wants as Klaus Schwab Palpatine
wants and then they hire based on race
and sexuality and gender and they make
sure that oh you've been vaxed so maybe
you'll get a promotion you weren't
vacced and you're white you're kind of
out man and a whole bunch more this is
exactly how it's working and what he
does this Klaus Schwab guy who of course
is unelected has no in in reality in the
reality of how things are supposed to
work should have no power over your life
he also comes off as a complete cartoon
character if you were if you were making
up the idea of the evil guy the evil
world leader I mean it's him the accent
it's all just perfect it's him but what
they then do is they have their little
world economic conferences obviously we
we covered the last one in Davos quite
extensively a couple weeks ago and then
they send the world leaders back to
their countries to Institute their
policies this is top down evil nonsense
we sent many many high-level American
officials there
[Music]
foreign